today the topic is Federated learning
with flower um ai's next Frontier and I
know that's quite a bold title but um
I'm I'm trying to live up to it so let
me start by um actually giving a little
bit of context on why we are doing this
um I thought about how to structure this
keynote and um I could dive very deep
into Federated learning and how it works
and all the different um algorithms that
are out there but I thought the much
more important piece is to actually put
it in context um frame why we should
actually be interested in doing this and
what this will enable and how this will
shape the next generation of AI
systems for doing that um you've
probably all um heard about the the the
great discussion about um GPU rich and
GPU poor and I think um there's another
there's a nice analogy that can be made
um where we not talk about GPU rich and
GPU poor but actually um the much more
important question is data rich or data
poor and I think there's no better place
to talk about this um than Pi
data so let me start by giving you in
quotes the secret recipe um for creating
uh the next AI
breakthrough AI has evolved around uh
three pillars and they model model
architecture model size compute and data
so if you look at the model architecture
the Breakthrough for deep learning was
sort of alexnet and in 2012 alexnet had
62 million parameters now a much more
recent model llama 2 has 70 billion
parameters it's quite a big difference
in terms of compute alexnet was trained
on a GTX um 580 or um several GDX 580 um
which had 1.5 um Tera flops of fp32
performance comparing that to um a much
more recent h100
sxm which has um almost close to 2,000
Tera flops of fp16 performance which is
um what we're training these days huge
difference um and it should be noted
that um models like Lama 2 they're not
just trained on one of these gpus but um
literally on thousands or even tens of
thousands of these
gpus and then on the DAT pillar um we
trained on IM image net in
2012 um what are we training on today
actually that's a topic um that I would
like to to go into um and show that this
is actually um the part of the this is
the one pillar of these three that
hasn't really um evolved that much over
over the last decade and there's a huge
opportunity
here if we look at uh some of the recent
AI Milestones um we can see that they're
all very very data hungry if we look at
llama 2 for example Lama 2 was
pre-trained on two trillion tokens if
you look at whisper in 2022 by open AI
this was trained on 680,000 hours of um
speech data so audio data which roughly
equals 77 .6 years like someone sitting
down and speaking for 70 years um
straight into a microphone without um
ever um taking a nap um that's the
amount of training data that went into
um training a competitive model here and
then last but not least in in
reinforcement learning open ai5 in 2019
was trained on 45,000 years of um DOTA
selfplay so we can um it's it's pretty
obvious here that um those AI
Milestones um the the really the
interesting models that that push the
boundaries of what possible they're very
very data
hungry so let's look at um what kind of
use cases what kind of tasks um could we
consider to be data rich and what kind
of other tasks could be considered to be
um data poor if you look at images
images that um are of the style like
images that you can find on the web that
I would um classify as data Rich um
there's a ton of images on the web
um you can find um a ton of selfies for
example on the web but then if you look
at image data um in more specialized
domains for example in healthcare that I
would consider um data poor so for
example it's easy to find a lot of
images um a lot of um holiday pictures
for example on the web but it's very
difficult um to find a lot of um MRI
scans on the web um other uh other
examples um video there's t of video
data on the web um but it's also um
quite generic again if you look at um
specialized video domains like
self-driving for example there are very
few videos of um a deer jumping in front
of a car on a snowy icy Road um going
uphill um on the Internet it's very
difficult to find these so companies
that attempt to um train on um self
train to uh uh train models for
self-driving um they need to sample
these videos themselves
for text Data there's also a ton of Text
data on the web but again um spe more
specialized data for example um text
that coming from uh legal contracts is
um more specialized and it's very
difficult to come across um on the web
so if you want to train a um a model for
some kind of legal AI use case it's um
difficult to do that with web scrape
data and um you're again in a in a in a
data poor domain speech data there's lot
of speech data especially um covering
the English language if we look at
languages other than English um speech
data is much more rare um and and for
some um languages very difficult to come
across so again um data poor domain for
reinforcement learning you have ton of
tons of data in reinforcement learning
when you do um simulation and when you
can um run lots of simulations in a in a
cheap fashion reinforcement learning in
the real world um is much more difficult
and um again we're in a data po domain
and there are certain types of um
verticals and industries um that that
could be considered um data Po from from
that perspective healthc care for
example um medical AI researchers um
they usually don't have access to to
tons of training data because this data
is very valuable and um there are tons
of regulations that prevent this data
from uh being freely shared being put on
on the internet um so it's it's
difficult for them um to to train latest
generation models because they're
lacking meaningful amounts of training
data similar situation in manufacturing
in uh Finance for example if you look at
um for example fraudulent transactions
in finance um these data points they
very rare and they're locked down in um
data silos within um in individual
financial institutions
and then um automotive and personal
Computing are are are similar settings
where some of the data can be collected
but a lot of the data actually that's
out there and that would be very
valuable for these these models um
cannot be easily
collected well um especially with uh
yesterday's news uh someone might say
well but now we have Gemini Gemini can
do everything actually um here's an
excerpt for the um Google Deep Mind um
Gemini tech report and um I'm quoting we
find that data quality is critical to a
highly performing model and believe that
many interesting questions remain around
finding the optimal data set
distribution for pre-training so that's
something uh they put in tech report
there unfortunately not a lot of
information about the training set they
used um largely um training data scraped
from the web but um if we wanted to
twist these words a little bit even um
even Gemini um is is sort of stating
that if they had better training data
Gemini would probably be um perform much
much
better so clearly this is a challenge
but um at the same time we want to look
at it um as an opportunity and we're in
we're in this interesting situation
today
where the data that is being used is um
actually just a small fraction of the
data we have in the world the data that
is used for training is public and or
centralized data so it's either data
scraped from the web or the limited
amount of uh training data that a single
Institution for example a single
research hospital um has internally but
there's actually much more data in the
world but this data is um either
sensitive so it's you can't find it on
the web or it's distributed it's
distributed across different
organizational silos it's distributed um
across user devices so it can't be used
um for for AI training
today why is that the case we we have
all of this data we want this data we
need it to train better models so why
can't we easily access it well the
classic machine learning approach is to
move the training data to the
computation so um in this uh diagram
here we can see a server in the middle
and then we can see some uh devices
but this could equally well be um
different institutions for example
different uh different hospitals that
want to uh work together um we have this
Central server and then before we can uh
train a machine learning model everyone
needs to upload all of their data to the
central server so user devices they need
to disclose all the um personally
identifiable
information if we had um hospitals um
clustered around this server then
hospitals would need to um disclose
patient data um to the
server well actually that's exactly
where the problem Lies We um the just
the pure fact that data needs to move in
many cases in many Industries in in many
very valuable tasks prevents us from
accessing uh enough training data
because the data um cannot move it's
either that um we have a lot of training
data on the edge for example or that we
have very sensitive TR training data for
example um credit card information or
personal messages in in encrypted chat
apps that um should not go to the server
and where users expect this data to
remain on device um or we have
regulations in place like um a hospital
um needing to hold on to their patient
data and and needing to safeguard it um
in other areas like for example Finance
we also have strong regulations where
even a single organization cannot um
centralize all of the data that they
have so they might have data in
different regions um maybe data in the
US data in Europe and data in Asia um
but because of local
regulations they cannot centralize this
uh this training data um even in their
own
infrastructure Federated machine
learning um Federated learning and
Federated
evaluation just um basically flips that
it says um okay instead of moving the
data data to the computation let's move
the computation to the data we're not
going to collect data anymore we'll
leave the data where it is the data
doesn't have to move and then we move
the computation to where the data is and
we perform um parts of the computation
there so we'll train the model locally
um on the local training data and then
instead of um moving training data
around we just move models around and
with that the data stays where it or
orates and we can suddenly start to
incorporate um all of the all of the
data that is out there but currently not
usable we can suddenly incorporate it um
into our training workloads so that
makes um the same situation where um in
a in a classic machine learning approach
that needs to move the data we would be
in a in a data poor environment makes it
suddenly data Rich environment because
we can um access all of this training
data how does it actually work under the
hood let's go through um a very basic
intuitive um explanation and then that
should hopefully um uh give you enough
understanding of it so that we can um
look at the at the math behind it real
quick um and and get a full
understanding of how this
works so we'll start with a um a server
uh Federated learning server in this
case the the flow server the flow server
um initializes a model so it's just a
randomly initialized model the model um
doesn't know anything um about the task
yet and that model um that model and and
the server has not seen any data so
there's not a single um data point on
the
server we then send the initialized
model that um doesn't know anything yet
we'll send this to the user devices for
example could be user devices could be
could be other types of um data
partitions um could be different
hospitals so we'll send the machine
learning model to where the data is to
those um in this case
phones and then each phone will train
the model for a little while using the
local data so um it has some some local
data that was collected through uh user
interaction with the device and it will
use that data to train the model just
for a little while maybe one Epoch um
but definitely not um until full
convergence so each of these devices
trains the model for a little while and
each of these devices then ends up with
um a slightly improved model so a model
that knows a little bit more um about uh
about the data um but each device
obviously because each device has
different training data each device ends
up with um a different model update so
after that that um that short um
training period on the device each
device sends the updated model back to
the server so we'll have the server um
we have the previous model and we have
the new models that are coming back from
those devices um now what do we do with
it well the last step is uh we aggregate
um those uh those models that we receive
we aggregate them into one new model and
a model that um that then hopefully has
learned something about um all of the
data that is distributed on on all of
those devices and after that we just
repeat we repeat this process over and
over again so we have an aggregated
model on the server we'll again send it
to those devices each device trains for
a little while sends the updated and
slightly improved model back to the
server and the server Aggregates them
again um we are not running a full
training on each device because that
would make the individual models that
are going back to the server two
different from each other and um
experiments have shown that um
approaches like like this um don't
converge very well um so that's the
reason why we only perform maybe a
single Epoch or five epochs um on the on
the local device and why we repeat this
process over and over
again with that um we should hope
hopefully have the full the enough of an
intuitive understanding to um look at
the actual algorithm from the um seminal
um paper on on Federated averaging this
approach is is called Federated
averaging um the paper is uh called
communication efficient learning of deep
networks from decentralized data so
there was a lot of EMP emphasis back
then on the communication aspects um but
the same approach um can be used in in
in settings where communication
efficiency is actually not that crucial
um so if you walk through um the
algorithm step by step we see um first
the first part of it is um what the
server executes and the second part of
it is what the client executes so what
the server executes is um before the
loop it initializes the model parameters
and then for a number of these rounds it
selects a um random subset of clients
that are out there so this is um
especially important in settings where
you have a large number of for example
mobile devices participating um in these
workloads
um Google Apple meta they have um these
systems in place um and they run
workloads across um sometimes hundreds
of millions of devices and then in such
a setup you don't want to um run on all
of these devices at the same time but
you want to select a small subset maybe
a few hundred maybe in in the low
thousands um but definitely not
more so um we select a subset let's say
we select uh 200 clients and then um to
each of those clients we send the um
model parameters that the server has um
initialized each of these clients does
do a typical um update um like like a
regular um centralized model training
would do so um we have the local data
partition we um split it into a number
of batches um and then for each batch we
um we perform um SGD and then after um
the local Epoch um one Epoch or maybe
five epochs something like that we send
the updated um and um hopefully improved
model parameters back to the server the
server receives all of these and then
what it does um to aggregate them in the
in the very simplest form it does
weighted average um it um The Waiting
happens based on the number of training
examples on each device so each
participating device usually has a has a
different number number of um training
data examples and based on that um we um
we average the model parameters and we
get a new um Global updated model and
with that new um Global globally updated
model we can then perform the next round
of U fed of um Federated averaging so
again uh we would select a subset set of
participating devices and um and and and
go through the same procedure again this
um algorithm is called uh Federated
averaging often abbreviated as um fed
AVG um and we'll see that later um in
code on on how it
works here's a small um animation that
um once again visualizes the the same
approach um data scientist initializes
the model model moves to the devices um
those devices they are holding on to to
their local training data they train the
model different models go back to the
server
and the server Aggregates them and then
we'll repeat this
process the same approach can be used
for evaluation in that case it's uh
called Federated evaluation so um what
we're doing is um we already have a
trained model but we want to know how it
performs and this is um often an often
overlooked approach I would say but a
very very um important one for certain
domains if you think about Healthcare
for example in healthcare um there's
many startups that are trying to train
better um medical AI models but it's um
we don't know how good those models are
because there's so so limited um we have
limited amounts of um of evaluation data
and we don't have like an objective
Benchmark on um on how to compare
different models that that are supposed
to do the same thing on how to compare
these um to each other so um in this
setting um there's initiative called um
met per for example and and and quite a
few other initiatives that are trying to
um set up a Federated network of data
nodes where different hospitals
contribute their data um to allow others
to evaluate their models and by doing so
um we will hopefully um soon get get to
a a critical mass of um hospitals each
contributing their patient data um and
then allow others to just evaluate their
models so no one has access to to train
on these models but people can just um
startups or larger pharmaceutical
companies um if they have models they
can run them on this um on this large
Federation of data nodes and then see um
and compare their their models in an
objective way um to to other
models one other related approach is f
analytics in that case um what we're
sending to these data partitions is um
actually not a model but it's something
closer to a SQL query for example and
then we query the local data um for
example we could um again um sticking
with the with the healthcare example we
could query different hospitals on um
the average age of um people getting a
certain disease and then on the server
side um we can we can aggregate these
results together and we'll get um a much
more um comprehensive answer because um
because the query um has has seen a lot
more tra um data um evaluation
data one thing I should add um before W
before we wrap up this section is um
unfortunately there's no free lunch so
Federated learning um if you look at it
um through the perspective of privacy
and security um can only be be really
private and secure um with a careful
holistic design so there's um there's
different things that need to be um
adjusted for um usually feder learning
is not used in isolation feder learning
is sort of just the enabling layer to
access more data but then other
approaches depending on the task and
depending on the threat model are
layered on top of it um so differential
privacy is a is a very important one um
another important one is secure
agregation and these um again depending
on the on the on the threat model
depending on a on a careful carefully um
designed um system architecture um
should be used together with Federated
learning um to to make these systems um
secure and and private by
Design
um let's go uh through a couple of
examples um and then I'll after those
examples I'll I'll I'll stop uh for a
second and I'm happy to take a couple of
questions um before we move on to to to
um an actual introduction into how this
uh can be done in code so Federal
learning examples um there's roughly
speaking there's there's two two big
categories of Federated learning one is
crosso Federated learning which means
training across different organizational
silos um popular example that we um
discussed um at length now is um
Healthcare where um also a big factor um
in health care is trustworthiness um in
machine learning so in healthcare um
again we have this situation where
different pharmaceutical companies or
startups um they are releasing models or
or they offer models to um for example
look at M scans or other kinds of
medical data and um and try to see um
what what kind of situation is there so
how can we um achieve a situation where
we can objectively compare all of those
models well federa evaluation is a um is
an important building block in that and
then after federa evaluation how can we
improve those models um the answer to
that would be um Federated
learning another important um case is
manufacturing uh we have um actually
quite a few users and organizations
we're working with in manufacturing and
they're facing the issue that each of
these manufacturing plants they're
usually um separate legal entities and
um they're based um around the globe in
in different um regions so it's very
difficult for these companies even if
they own all of the subsidiaries to
centralize all of the training data in
addition to that there's tons of
training data within each of these um
manufacturing plants so um the sheer
technical task of creating a system that
centralizes all of this data is quite a
difficult one um so in that case um
organizations realize that it's much
easier to just keep the data where it is
and then to connect these different
manufacturing plants for things like
predictive um maintenance for example so
detecting faults before they actually
happen
um another interesting one we touch upon
is finance uh so in finance again data
is heavily regulated and um usually um
data for example that is um generated in
the US it cannot be freely moved um to
other regions around the world um which
is a good thing for customers but for
data scientists it U poses a challenge
so even if it's just a single Bank um
that is um that operates in multiple
regions um these organizations are very
interested in using Federated learning
because suddenly they can incorporate
all of the data they have in different
regions without violating um any any of
the regulations that are that have been
put in place there the other big
category of uh Federate learning is
called cross device Federated learning
which means um training across different
user devices so imagine a single company
that has maybe an application out there
um with with a large number of users
then um those users are all generating
data but not all of the data can be and
and should be collected on the server
side um personal Computing is is is
obviously the big one um so um
incorporating for example um very
privacy sensor itive data into um into
training workloads that sits on devices
um text models are a very good example
it's actually uh one of the very first
Federated learning use cases um that has
been been publicized was to train the
Android keyboard um um and then to train
better prediction in the Android
keyboard so whenever you type a couple
of characters you get these predictions
and suggestions for um autoc completing
what you were about to type and the
model that um sits behind that um that
model is trained using Federated
learning on a very large Fleet of of
hundreds of millions of
devices another one that doesn't
immediately come to mind uh when think
about cross device F learning is
Automotive um actually quite a few
Automotive companies are very interested
in adopting this approach because again
um different local regulations force
them to uh or prevent them uh from
actually collecting data that is um that
is generated in the car just through the
through the regular Act of driving the
car in different environments um there's
actually very interesting data on those
cars for for for automotive companies
but U because of regulations they cannot
collect it and and some of the data they
also should not collect it if if there's
a camera um that uh that um watches the
pass passengers whether maybe the driver
is falling asleep then um that is data
um that should not be collected
centrally but obviously um such systems
can be vastly improved um through
machine learning
models okay before we move on to flower
um maybe let's take a question or two um
and then we we can
continue looking at the chat
um does flower use some type of
heuristic to discover what type of
training task to do supervised
unsupervised reinforcement learning when
model is moved to data locally it is
Federated um fler doesn't do that out of
the box because um flower takes an
agnostic perspective so the perspective
of flower is to say um we want to
provide generic infrastructure that
enables you to um to build whatever task
you're um interested in um on top of so
we're not prescribing a certain approach
and we're not um doing this for the user
but we provide um sort of a plug-in
architecture where you where users can
choose the best approaches and then um
combine those to um to build whatever
system whatever is right for their
particular use
case Okay um looking at the Q&A
section um put one on the screen if you
want to take a look at
that oh there's one on the screen um
give me a
second how would Federate averaging work
for tabular data would the concept limit
kind of algorithms you could use um yes
that's true so for different kinds of
models there's different kinds of a
aggregation algorithms Federated
averaging Works um still um after all
these years surprisingly well for models
like uh neural networks but then if you
work with um tabular data um very
popular approach um on tabular data is
to use for example XG boost and um for
XG boost there's different types of
aggregation algorithms that aggregate
those um trees on the server side and it
Al also have customizations on the
client side um so that's something that
um in the case of that Frameworks like
flower they usually build an an an
abstraction that allows you to pick the
right um aggregation algorithm on the
server side so not not every um uh ation
algorithm is compatible with every kind
of
model yeah very good question um all
right in the interest of time um let's
move on so as you could see um from from
the previous sections there's a lot of
um moving of data and um in involvement
of clients not moving of training data
but data related to um model parameters
and for all of that obviously um we need
some kind of infrastructure our
hypothesis is um that these uh
approaches are still too difficult to
use for many which is why we build
infrastructure to make it um a lot
easier um for people to take existing
machine learning approaches and bring
them into this new paradig of uh
Federated learning and this is
essentially what uh what we call flower
this is U the flower op Source framework
FL is completely open source on uh on
GitHub um everyone can um
install it uh can use it and can
contribute to it we actually have um
much more um in terms of raw numbers we
have much more contributors from the
community than the core team of
maintainers itself um flow's perspective
is that the missing piece to um take
these approaches mainstream and to um
enabling more organizations to to
benefit and and to creating a data Rich
environment for themselves is that um
the infrastructure um is is is um is is
still not where it should be and that's
why we're building um flour and we um
our perspective is that um we need a
unified approach for Federated learning
Federated
analytics evaluation that makes it very
easy to um to bring existing projects
into this new paradigm and I'll show um
what this means in a second on the right
hand side this is something like a a
rough architecture diagram um you can
see there's a flower server you can see
there different flower clients connected
to it each with the with with the model
running and those different clients um
one thing that's uh that fler um is is
um that's a little bit unique about fler
is that it supports very very different
kinds of clients so there could be
everything from um a laptop to a um
Linux server to a supercomputer but then
also much smaller devices like um uh an
Android phone an IO phone um and maybe
even a car um connected to the very same
server um running and participating in
the very same workload and in order to
do that we need to do quite a few things
we need to support Android and iOS
python cross Silo cross device
horizontal vertical differential privacy
secure aggregation secure multi party
computation um and we need to um support
all of these paradigms um in a
simulation um setting where users can
simulate this and um also operations um
to really fully deploy these systems and
we try to um build one solution that
allows you um to to do all of that um
but only learn a stack
once so the flower ecosystem in order to
do that um allows you to integrate with
um all the tools you know in love we
support pretty much every machine
learning framework out there and a lot
of other um aot a lot of other popular
tools like um weights and biases for
example to to log your
examples um another big aspect that I
just briefly touch upon is um this idea
of taking a single solution a single
framework to move from um development
all the way to deployment and in
Federate learning that's a bit more
complex than in some some other Stacks
so we support development on a single
machine then uh you can move this um
this this uh first prototype for example
you can move this onto a larger compute
cluster to simulate a large number of um
of devices um you can also simulate the
same thing on on a real device cluster
if you're targeting uh mobile devices
for example that's that's quite an
important aspect of it and then um later
on you can you can use the very same um
code base and project to deploy it um to
a large Fleet of
devices simulation performance is
something we put a lot of effort in uh
what you can see on this chart is how
many um the total number of clients that
are in in a client pool and then also
how many of these clients you can run
concurrently in a simul simulation those
numbers are quite old um but you can see
that um compared to what um research
settings usually look at um flower is in
in in a completely different
ballpark um there's a lot of research
that went into the design and
Engineering of the framework I'm not
going to um list all of the papers but
here's a rough architecture diagram that
sort of shows the layered Arch ecture
where um on the client side you have the
regular um training Pipeline and uh the
client side data which is very similar
to um centralized machine learning but
then on the server side we have this
concept of a strategy that um sort of
allows you to um gives you sort of a
plug-in architecture for aggregation
algorithms also for um how to configure
those individual clients for trading um
which clients to select um and makes
these things these components isolated
and very easy to build and and
contribute to and also customize
obviously um flower is a large community
um this is something we're quite excited
about because we get tons of
contributions people are building a lot
on top of it and and the feedback we get
from that um mainly drives the the road
map that we have for flower um in terms
of numbers I think it's very safe to say
that um developers um love flower we
have 100 computers um more than 100
actually um we have more than a thousand
projects on GitHub that depend on flower
um so this is always projects where
someone else published um their own
project which depends on flower uh we
have 2,800 um more than more than that
um developers on the flower slack and we
have more than 3.3k stars in GitHub and
as you can see here in this plot this is
GitHub Stars plotted on the globe um
what we quite love about this is that
we're not just Pres in the in the usual
Tech hubs around the world but really we
have this Global Community U that is um
that um is coming together to build
this um we'd appreciate a star on GitHub
uh so the GitHub URL is github.com
aapf flower um I believe it's also um I
I also added this to the resources here
on um
airme and then um now it's already time
to go into a live
demo let me stop sharing my screen for a
second and then um bring up the live
demo okay you should be able to see see
my full screen now and um I'm just going
to walk through a project um this is a
simple Federated learning project with
um um pytorch and flow and as you can as
you will see um most of the code is just
the regular um pytorch sort of Hell
World project and then there's very
little code needed to um take this
existing project and um Federated using
flower so what we can see here is um
we're starting with the with the client
side because that's where the actual
model training happens what we can see
here is um first of all a number of
imports and then what follows is just a
regular pytorch training pipeline so the
an module um the training function a
test function and a data loader uh we're
starting with the NN module um the NN
module this is just a a very simple
simple conval neural network with number
of fully connected um layers this is um
we did not author this originally this
is actually just a simple CNN adopted
from the pytorch um the
tutorial we then have a training
function also a very simple one the
training function what um takes the
neural network itself it takes a
training loader and the number of epochs
um that should be trained and then
similar to that we also have a test or
evaluation function which just takes the
um neural network and a test data loader
and then um does the
evaluation and then last but definitely
not least we have a low data function um
we are using a library here called um
flower data sets um this is a library we
released fairly recently which can be
used to easily partition existing data
sets so if you wanted to simulate a
Federated system you would usually go
ahead and take an existing data set like
C4 10 and then um and then partition it
into mul multiple chunks so that you can
um use each of these chunks to simulate
um different data on on on different
clients and in that case we are doing
just that we're taking C4 10 and we're
partitioning it into three partitions so
that's there to simulate three clients
and um to determine which one to load we
we pass a note ID here we could also
call this a client
ID that's the regular pyo training
pipeline so we could put this all
together in a um in a main function and
then um call the training and um
evaluate after
training now we move on to um the
Federated part of it so a little bit of
um just just admin code here um we
enable when we start the script we add a
D-
node-id so we can um we can pass in
which uh data partition to load and then
after that we
create an instance of our model and we
load the data for this particular node
ID and now comes the small part of code
that's actually needed to Federate this
model and the the the Federated part of
it is um we are wrapping this this
existing training pipeline we're just
wrapping this in what we call a flower
client so flower offers um this this
convenient um CL convenience class
called numpy L to make it easy to um
Federate pipelines that are um that are
compatible with numpy and what we do for
that is I'm going to discuss the the
last two functions first we're going to
have a fit function uh fit fit method
and an evaluate method so the fit method
when the client runs it receives the
parameters that are coming from the
server so the the current um the latest
version of the global model and it
receiv a configuration that can be used
to tell the client for example um how
many Epoch to
train what we do then is um first we
call set parameters which causes the
local model to be updated so the local
model still has um old parameters we
just received um a fresh set of
parameters from the server so we're
updating the um the the local model
after that we call the train function uh
we pass the updated model um and the the
train loader that has the local training
data this trains the model and then
after the training we again extract the
updated model parameters so the slightly
improved model and we also returning um
the number of um local um local batches
used or local trading
examples to the server to do um the
weighted
averaging and then um evaluation works
in the same way we up up a local model
um we run the test function and we um
instead of the updated model parameters
we return the loss and um and we also
return um the accuracy to the server and
then to start the whole thing uh it's
just one function start client um we
tell it um the address of the server so
it can connect to the server and uh we
create an instance of client and um pass
this to start client that's the client
side the server side could be as little
as um a single line of code I added a
little bit more um to make it um more
obvious what's going on so um to the
server we passed this strategy in this
case we're using fat averaging but
there's quite a few other strategies so
if I just um open the auto complete here
we can see fat Yogi fed procs fed adrad
a lot of others um and those are just
the ones that um start with fat there's
also um XG boost based ones um because
we had this question earlier um and and
then we could easily switch to to a
different strategy here um and I also
have this function to aggregate this
custom um this custom metric um the
accuracy on the server side going into
um the actual code um we can see four
terminal Windows now on the top this
will be our server let's start the
server which is just Python server.py
and then we have three more windows um
which are there to simulate three
clients so let's start the first client
um python client.py um and then node ID
zero so that client is now starting up
it's connecting to the server we're
starting the second
client with the node ID
one and as soon as it's running it
receives the training task um the server
is waiting for the second client to
connect um because it um is configured
that way you could would also tell the
server to wait for at least three
clients or at least 500 clients before
it starts the training and then um we
see these multiple rounds so we see the
the first round of training we see the
first round of evaluation we see another
round of training and then after the
whole thing is finished we can see that
um the distributed loss is going down
and we can see that um the accuracy is
going up from um 14% to8 to um 21 in
that case not very good just three
rounds uh and probably not optimal
hyperparameters but just to Showcase how
this works now let's tell the server to
wait for at least three
clients just change that let's start the
server again let's start uh the first
client let's start the second
client and then we wait for the second
for a second and we see that nothing
happens because we configur the strategy
in a different way we said uh Min
available clients is three um this
causes the strategy to wait until at
least three clients are there so let's
start um third client now and then the
training should
commence and we can see that it's
starring to run and um we'll we'll we'll
see a similar um situation as we saw
before
that concludes the live demo I'll stop
sharing that part of the screen now and
I'll go back
to my
slides
um if you're interested in diving deeper
um there's obviously a lot more to learn
there's a full tutorial on Flor the def
um just on the landing page there's a
big button uh take the
tutorial and now I would would like to
wrap up and and leave quite a bit of
time for questions um by talking just a
little bit and very briefly about uh
future
directions so our vision and the reason
why we're working on this infrastructure
and why we're working on Flow and the
whole ecosystem around FL is that we
want to
see important industries like healthcare
uh we want to see these industries to
become datar rich environments we want
the breakthroughs that we seeing in
other domains where we already have data
Rich environments we want these
breakthroughs to become available we
want um healthc care for example to be
transformed um through the through the
ways that um AI gives us these days um
and in order to achieve that we need to
we need to have infrastructure that
allows us to turn these different
domains into Data Rich
environments same can be said for
manufacturing same can be said for for
Finance um Finance is for example very
interesting one where we see fraudulent
transactions each financial institution
needs to try to find fraudulent um
interactions um to prevent crime on a
global scale and only through um better
machine learning models we can we can
better detect um those fraudulent
transactions and we can only get to
better machine learning models if we
again turn um turn the finance domain
into a data R
domain same can be said for um personal
Computing um no one wants their personal
data to be disclosed and um potentially
on a server that uh that could be hacked
and data could be leaked um so if we can
BR bring those advances of machine
learning to um the domain of personal
Computing but keep data private then um
every single one of us will benefit from
that same can be said for automo motive
we all want safer cars and uh less
traffic and less accidents and in order
to achieve that um many of these things
can be achieved by just building better
models that um detect If a driver is
sleepy that detect dangerous situations
and that prevent cars from um from
crashing into each
other last but definitely not least um I
want to say if this is interesting to
you uh we just announced a number of POS
positions um uh and we are actively
hiring so if you're interested in that
um check out careers. flower. death and
our next Community event is coming up
flower Summit in 2024 dates will be
announced um pretty soon it will happen
in March um either in person in London
or um online with a with a live
stream and that's a WP um I hope this
was interesting to you and I'm very
happy to um take uh questions now
awesome thank you so much Daniel we have
a bunch of questions let me put some
questions on
stage first
one um I'm going to read out the
question um to distribute training
across silos you would need to assure
that the data has the same format how
are you dealing with this INF Federated
learning great question um and important
one um that's absolutely true that we
need um data of the of the same same uh
same shape same format the way you can
do this is um in flow in in particular
that's the framework I know best um you
have um a lot of flexibility on the
client side so I've just the the way I
started the client was um sort of the
the hell World way of doing it um where
you have the the very same code running
on each client but then uh what you can
also do is you can customize this on a
per organization or per Silo basis so
you could for example customize the data
loading and then um transform the data
from uh its original format into a
common shared um format another way that
um to do this which is probably um a bit
more common is to um just locally have
some kind of um transformation layer
that runs every once in a while and that
outputs the um the original data in a in
a common shared format and then
everywhere um every single note that
participates in such a federation can
run the exact same code because um we
have the exact same um data format but
the big Advantage obviously is that um
all of these organizations that are
participating they can they can keep the
data in its original format in their
original system systems they don't need
to change anything about their systems
it's just an additional add-on layer
that sort of pulls the data transforms
it and then makes it available to the
Federation in a unified
format awesome thank you let me get on
the next
question do you plan for to be like a
marketplace where data owners can offer
their um data assets for training this
is something that has been um this idea
has been sort of floated a couple of
times to us um right now flower is only
an open source framework um and you can
use the open source framework um you can
contact us to to help you when you if
you if you want to deploy these systems
but um as of today you still have to uh
run FL yourselves we'll probably at some
point because there is quite a bit of
demand for it um also offer hosted
solutions to make this easy easier but
um a data Marketplace I would say is
something it's it's a very interesting
idea and I think there could be some
potential in it but it's something
that's definitely um years off and and
and the demand that we see for these
kinds of systems is um is is in a
different area I think right now a lot
of um individual organizations are
exploring this because they can deploy
it very quickly and solve their own um
solve their own problems and then I
think in the long run this could become
um more of the thing as organizations um
get more familiar with the idea of
Federated systems maybe they've deployed
some Federated systems um internally
across different regions for example if
it's a multinational organization and um
as they become familiar with this kind
of system
architecture um they will um I think um
become also this this idea of data
market places um where still everyone
has full control over their data and
what happens to their data I think is a
very powerful one but it's not something
that will um I guess happen in the in
the next six months or
so for security is any code sent from
server to clients or just parameters are
sent great question um this is something
that is configurable so for and and this
depends a lot on the kind of system
you're running and the kind of
requirements um you have so um security
obviously is a is is of utmost
importance and in situations where the
client does not trust the server um
fully there's um there's no need or
there's a way to configure the client to
just run with the code that it has has
locally and there's no way for the
server to send any code um to the client
to just execute and that's a very
important property that's very important
um to um to make this possible that's
actually um in flower that's the default
and the default is C the client would
never execute any code that is coming
from the server that being said um in
some environments it's actually wanted
that the client can execute code from
coming from the server so imagine a
situation
where um there's a single organiz
organization that's under in in control
of all um all all the different data
nodes and it just wants to um deploy a a
pilot system and and just experiment um
a lot with um and and learn how these
workloads are behaving so in that case
it can actually be very beneficial to um
allow Dynamic code execution the client
it's not a it's not the the secure way
to run system but for prototyping and
and explor um explorative projects it
can be quite quite beneficial and in in
in such cases um this will be possible